la crisis climática es una bomba de
tiempo y el tiempo se acaba en su sexto
informe el grupo intergubernamental de
expertos sobre el cambio climático
advirtió que las medidas tomadas para
luchar contra el calentamiento global
son insuficientes y que nos acercamos a
un punto de inflexión que llevaría a
graves impactos y reversibles
la humanidad está sobre un hielo delgado
y ese hielo se está derritiendo
rápidamente como detalla el informe de
hoy del panel intergubernamental sobre
el cambio climático los humanos son
responsables de Prácticamente todo el
calentamiento global en los últimos 200
años
la tasa de aumento de la temperatura en
el último medio siglo es la más alta en
2000 años la concentración de dióxido de
carbono está en su punto más alto en al
menos dos millones de años la bomba del
tiempo climática está en marcha
sin embargo los expertos informan que
existe la posibilidad de garantizar un
futuro habitable y sostenible a todos
siempre y cuando haya una acción
inmediata la ventana de oportunidad se
cierra rápidamente por lo que piden que
las emisiones de carbono sean reducidas
a la mitad para 2030 la ONU insta a los
países desarrollados a comprometerse con
una adelanto de los objetivos en materia
de neutralidad de emisiones pasando del
objetivo fijado en 2050 a 2040
el límite de 1.5 grados Celsius es
alcanzable pero ahora falta un salto
cuántico en la acción climática este
informe es un toque de atención para que
todos los países todos los sectores y
todos los plazos aceleren masivamente
sus esfuerzos por el clima en resumen
nuestro mundo necesita una acción
climática en todos los frentes todo en
todas partes al mismo tiempo
el mundo experimenta actualmente
1,1 grados de calentamiento En
comparación con la temperatura de la era
preindustrial el aumento de los
fenómenos extremos como picos de calor
inundaciones o ciclones Ya se está
produciendo en todos los continentes si
el mundo continúa por la vía actual el
calentamiento sería de más de tres
grados para finales de siglo con
consecuencias difíciles de